a deleted scene from the Elvis biopic
features none other than one of
country's biggest movie stars well sort
of here's how an early cut of the film
nearly paired the kick with one of
country's most lasting talents the
critically acclaimed biopic Elvis
provides an intimate glimpse into the
legendary performer's life its Dynamic
approach to Presley is supported by
Austin Butler's striking portrayal of
the performer which helped him win a
Golden Globe for best performance by an
actor in a motion picture drama the
Project's bold visuals and Lively
soundtrack give it a rhythmic quality
worthy of Presley's Legacy credit for
this vibrant blend goes to Elvis
director baz luhrmann his previous work
has a style all its own bringing
together inspired choices from the
Realms of art film pop culture
literature and music for Elvis the
director once again came up with a
soundtrack that utilizes top talents
from today and the performers signature
songs new contributions from dojicat and
Eminem alongside Presley's most famous
songs it also remixes some of the the
singer's catalog for dramatic effect
lerman's use of music to amplify a
moment where emotion is on Full display
throughout the movie still the director
regrets losing out on one song the
track's placement in a crucial scene
along with the meaning behind it tips
its hat to a beloved musical icon one of
the final scenes of Elvis is a
heartbreaking look at the artists then
harrowing life sitting alone with
ex-wife Priscilla Presley Elvis worries
that people will forget him
and nobody's gonna remember me it's a
portrait of a singer facing an uncertain
future as the world he knew collapses
for the filmmaker this moment shows how
Elvis and his first wife remained on
good terms after their split but it also
amounts to a death scene Lerman told
variety I always wanted another moment
where Priscilla came back into his life
and that they were friends in a way when
he walks on that plane and it takes off
we don't need to see him die he's dead
the interview also gave Lerman a chance
to speak on Elvis saying I will always
love you to Priscilla before he boards
the plane the backstory relates to a
missed opportunity between music royalty
namely Presley and Dolly Parton in the
film Elvis was set to sing the famous
song to Priscilla in those Quiet Moments
in the car Lerman made the decision to
do away with the brief moment but not
before acknowledging why the scene
didn't make the cut the director
explained to variety we just didn't know
how we would fit it into the schedule
you can't drive the car because of
gasoline so it's my guy Fletch pulling
the car with a piece of rope there's no
plane and no no tarmac just a wind
machine and the actors in real life
Elvis Presley planned to perform Dolly
Parton's legendary song I will always
love you but it seems once again that
his longtime manager Colonel Tom Parker
had the final say the problem was a
disturbing one for songwriter Parton who
was allegedly asked to give up half her
publishing rights by Parker pardon told
W in a 2021 interview I wanted to hear
Elvis sing it and it broke my heart I
cried all night but I had to keep that
copyright in my pocket you have to take
care of your business Parton went on to
explain that Elvis did actually sing I
Will Always Love You to Priscilla when
the two of them divorced a gesture which
she says touched her and while she had
to wait until 1992 before the song
became a huge hit on the billboard pop
charts courtesy of the late Whitney
Houston she remains proud of its lasting
Legacy pardon told W they also played
the song at Whitney Houston's funeral
after that I thought I bet they'll play
the same song when I go
[Music]
foreign
[Music]